[Applause]
[Music]
you know a lot of buzz in the industry
now is the the weeds that you're not
killing with the herbicides you know
well we really don't have on our farm we
really don't have a lot of problems with
that and I think that can be attributed
to using you know the small grains in
the rotation and keeping it diverse
because of that diversity in your crop
rotation you also have a diversity in
your herbicides that you can choose you
know whether your fries or your posts
you know and so you've got multiple
layers there too for weed suppression
right and so it all works together yeah
so I'm assuming you know what you're
making savings on inputs as well
herbicides is that correct yeah and part
of that is just because we don't have
the weed pressure yeah and so we don't
have to go out there more than twice a
year to knock these weeds back and still
have escapes you know you know it's
pretty much by placing your pre and then
if you have to do a post your field is
clean got a diverse mix now of radish
bench and lentils you know you've got
this natural action from these plants
that are digging deep down breaking up
compaction while still providing those
nutrients in that zone for the next year
and those roots for those that next
year's crop does not have to look very
far to find those nutrients that it
needs
[Music]